you ever hear seven nation army
is that
white stripes yeah yeah oh no i haven't
haven't got that very good it's like
this
that's harmonizing that sounds really
good
i have moments where i'm singing and
somebody says i'm like [ __ ] jesus
that was good yeah you guys ever have
that no no no with you no no no
i noticed i cleared my throat right in
that moment just in case you guys are
like let's hear yeah again give us a
little
example
[Music]
you gotta touch the ear
i think i'm better than mateo at singing
i agree yeah you're in better shape
definitely
do you really think you're better than
mateo i mean well he he has something
yeah sure he's got the whoa
whoa but i feel like i have the like
mine's sexier
a breathy soul a breathy sound yeah he
did uh
he did les miz when he was in here and
my reaction to that was very different
from my reaction to your singing i'm
glad i lay missed that
god damn it joe we should go to break
nailed down
hot dog yeah no i would say that he is
better than you ed singer i don't know i
haven't heard enough of joe i mean you
can't have if because you love matteo
what he's singing you can't that's true
i am a fan of the show you want to show
tune something you know
good morning good morning we talked the
whole night through good morning good
morning to you
well that's actually very good that was
very good that was very good kind of
low-key flat that's how i like a song
but you know i mean i think yeah you're
right like matteo has a skill set right
like there's a certain
song that speaks to his heart elaine he
has elaine yes yeah i think
joe when it comes to you would probably
be like
what speaks to your heart yeah
would probably be the fair comparison
and sam's face is unironically revolting
in this video the adoration
just because you don't like it that's
what it says it's dree's dreaming it's
incredible it's an incredible talent
yes
i think i can do this you do i'm sure
you could
i would love to hear you try this oh you
know he means stare lovingly at mateo
[Laughter]
why don't i just do sam's job
oh the hand on the chest oh i got the
vapors [ __ ] fruit
i like the song
i don't know which face is worse to
watch
it's an amazing show
yeah but it's into it it's when sam's
eyes narrow and he's like guiding him
into it
i was humming this to myself for i mean
months after this
it just doesn't reach me though all
right
i don't like it
that's probably my favorite part
matteo's version i'm enjoying a lot he's
incredible but the song itself would
never i would never seek it out
watching your hand clutch your chest i
wish it was for different reasons
this song stinks that's not true
you're not i'm not i gotta sit here and
listen to you guys poop on born to run
yes
this is a love story that takes place in
the middle of the french revolution yeah
[ __ ] the french revolution who cares
born to run takes place right in the
american revolution
yeah
dislike both of them then i'm usually
exclusive is that that's not a see-saw
yeah are you finding yourself in that
place yeah i don't know
i like born to run more than i like the
i like his version of this but i would
never listen to this if he didn't say i
don't think that there's anything that
joe list could sing that would move me
the way matteo moved me the french
revolution
was really something to see
why is that that different that's very i
feel like when i watch an opera
or i don't watch opera but when i see a
clip yeah i'm like
how different is that it's pretty
similar yeah i think it is it's pretty
and nobody's come to you and gone like
oh i have an employment opportunity for
you with this traveling opera not
employment but i do get a lot of people
that are like whoa hey that was really
oh my god better than i thought it would
be yeah a lot of people
yeah a lot of people are like what can't
you do and i'm like i don't know besides
comedy
[Laughter]
one time i was going up to uh montreal
not one time a hundred times going up to
montreal when we were young new england
boys looking to you know look at the
tits canadian strip clubs yeah and right
when we got into montreal i put on
panama and then when the the chorus came
out i turned it down and went canada
that's killed
killed they still talk about it back
there that's cool
what time would you be into this this i
feel like this might be up your alley we
got i hated it though me and for my
buddies we got like uh we went to the
strip club and you get like a a private
show with two ladies and they're doing
like a double dong thing yeah and one of
the women goes what's your name and i go
i'm joe and she goes oh i'm joe my dick
is so small i got a small
dick i was like
what are you doing i hate that
like she thought like ah you seem like a
guy who wants to his dick is small
that's a very specific kink and if
you're not into it it's the opposite you
never want to make the assumption no i
wouldn't be into that unless it was
one-on-one i don't like big you know
public it was one-on-one and a girl was
telling me how much better a bigger [ __ ]
was and it was dirty but if it felt
performative no it would do nothing yeah
that i think i could get into if my wife
was like i gotta come clean i'm
disappointed with your [ __ ] yeah that
might be like i need to be filled
properly yeah i get it i get it i'm not
cutting the mustard i gotcha
as i'm saying it out loud i'm like no i
would hate that but i mean
but this woman just being like oh joe's
got a tiny dick and i was like what the
[ __ ] i just gave you all of my money
yeah like [ __ ] you you know a hundred
percent of your my money is in your
possession and you're saying my dick is
small she probably didn't realize you're
cool yeah that's exactly right and i
don't know why people don't understand
that yeah that's a good point you have a
cool vibe
look at how i'm sitting yeah on the show
elbows there's a lot of care in the
world you're so chill you're coming out
here you're like these are the tunes i'm
into yeah here's some jokes i made one
at the monster truck rally one when i
was driving to canada i'm just a cool
dude i can literally feel the mean
comments in my pocket right now no when
i get out of here you [ __ ] loser yeah
it's because they're jealous they're not
cool yeah that's a good point yeah
that's what you got a good distance yeah
don't forget that sometimes they hate us
because they ain't us you know what i
mean
i went from mandolin to mma which i feel
like not many people have made that
transition you were going alphabetically
obviously
on my bucket list uh alphabetically were
you better are you better at mma or
mandolin
uh well now i'm better at mma because
i've been doing it
but yeah i mean i i took a little while
off because of um
and [ __ ] are you doing what are you
doing jiu jitsu it's like jiu jitsu well
it's mixed
that's the first time
um martial arts oh cool yeah cool uh so
we do standing striking some uh you know
kicking and all that horse [ __ ] and jiu
jitsu yeah but then he kicked me in the
uh like in the chest the other day and i
have a lingering
issue and it's like the houdini died i
think
seriously yeah well you got punched in
the stomach yeah you used to let people
punch him as hard as they could in the
stomach because he like knew how to
tense his gut abs yeah and then he ended
up getting punched too hard in the
stomach one day and he died well this
was so light i am such a just uh well
you're not houdini i am i snake i mean
he kicked me like
i'm gonna do it like this
like it was like 40
and it's like three weeks ago and i
moved i'm like oh
and then i'm just not cut out for it we
were sparring and for the first time
ever in like three years he threw a
punch and i countered and caught him on
the face and i put up both hands and
apologized i'm like i'm really sorry and
then he [ __ ] uppercut me in the face
and he's like you can't you got to stop
you can feel him being like dude this
what are you doing what do you think
we're doing here but i'm not i connect
with somebody's face and i'm like oh my
god i'm terribly sorry do you listen to
jackson brown that's true
[Laughter]
do you feel more secure on the subway
like do you feel like if there were not
that you would if a professional fighter
came around and kicked your ass but
could you defend yourself could you
defend yourself or maybe from an
accoster your wife if somebody was a
costume from a smasher i've had several
acostas this year and i've run from all
of them you still have a flight you've
had a clusters on the subway not in the
subway but uh one in in salt lake city
and in austin i had guys get aggressive
when you walk in
town
yeah boston you told us what about what
about salt lake cause it can be kind of
quiet on those streets they're not
always packed i also want to know like
what's going on with you that like when
a costars see you they target you when
strippers see you they say you have a
small penis i think it's the glasses the
jawline the face the forehead the
personality the herpes it's a lot of
stuff it's it's a conglomerate but
um somebody
said that to me like what are you doing
and i'm like well i tell them i have 40
bucks they have to fight me for it i
don't know if that's a bad idea
i have to confess i just did a joke for
my act on the radio show i appreciate it
um yeah
so what when
um the one in salt lake city was scared
because i was on the phone with a woman
not my wife like a friend sure but it is
a woman nice and we were talking and
it's embarrassing because we're talking
and you know we're talking uh
you know life [ __ ] and i'm trying to be
like yeah well here's what you gotta do
and then she's like talking jackson
brown once said yeah exactly and she's
like sad and like you know i'm just
depressed i don't know what to do about
and i'm like well here's the thing i was
like i had to like interrupt her yeah
hold on hold on i got there's like a
couple of suspicious guys and i can hear
her like okay where were you like
outside the hotel or this is in downtown
salt lake city but like you said a lot
of these cities there's just nobody out
yeah i i think covid was detrimental to
the nation
i hadn't seen it i've heard people say
that uh but apparently
yeah it's a good take actually i've even
researched that opinion i think it
caused a couple issues personally but
i mean i didn't want to get
controversial this morning
so you're on the phone and what are they
doing so i saw i heard an argument i saw
two guys in the distance because i'm
walking and they were yelling at each
other which i'm always anxious because
it's not like they're like well leave
him alone because we're having this is
between us yeah usually if you if you
look they get involved whatever
and then um
i passed one guy one guy started walking
he passed
and then i saw over here to my right
another guy i didn't know and i think
they were the ones fighting and then a
third guy was up here it was a little
pack and he had a bike
and he went he looked at me and goes
and like screamed like a wrestling promo
and i went i'm sorry i'm sorry and he
started running at me with the bike so i
just took off running and i was like i'm
sorry
and this woman was like do you want me
to call 9-1-1 i could hear her i'm like
shut up you [ __ ] just leave me alone
and so i read because he was on a bike
and there was three of them i was in a
triangulation of
fire like jfk sure yeah and um
so i ran but that one up on it i might
have jumped the gun well he couldn't
catch you on a bike well he ran next to
the bike but in my mind he was going to
get on the bike but he never did so i
just ran and ran i was just [ __ ] with
you yeah they were [ __ ] around with
me and then he was like
doing that thing
yeah and you're just running i just ran
like a small child wood yeah so so yes
okay so like your mma training has not
given you any additional confidence well
there's a fella by the name of joe rogan
yep don't know him yeah yeah yeah yeah i
don't listen to him because i'm a new
young guy but yeah
he got thrown off spotify so neil
young's fans still have something to
listen to i believe i love neil young
but um i don't care for his take but
i'm probably
um i mean that's insane but
[Laughter]
hey hey my my um
you won't have that right well that's
[ __ ]
yeah he's fantastic but he's got a lot
of [ __ ] i will admit neil young has like
more [ __ ]
than great great yeah at this point okay
but it's a lot more than four songs but
averages out today i've never heard more
than four that i liked but i mean i
probably said more with jim on that but
i don't know
i'm not i may be ignorant i don't know
i'm willing to admit that but it does
probably average out to [ __ ] yeah if
it's more bad than good anyway it's you
know you are
like a hurricane anyways so joe rogan
told me i did the right thing by running
away and you shouldn't try to fight
these guys and he he's dabbled in mixed
martial does he know mma he knows a
couple things so
he said i did the right thing but i i
there was another one in new york where
a guy kind of went like like that and i
did shift into a fighting stance and i
was with ron on hershberg i don't know
if you guys know ronna he's a wonderful
comedian but he's like a chubby jew
which is the best guy to be with because
he was like that was insane he's like
you got into fighting that was crazy
what did the guy do when you did that he
kept moving on he just did like ah i
kept walking but i jumped and kind of
shifted into this thing like
instinctively it felt good it didn't
make you feel good yeah it made me feel
good especially because
if like a normal regular person was
there they would have been like oh let's
keep walking that was crazy can't watch
this cobra kai yeah but i mean
in the cab rondon was like i mean it
that was really something that was
really impressive don't worry about it
uh so that was exciting trying to figure
out how to like downplay it without
getting him to stop talking you want him
to keep it yeah i was like well it was
nothing don't even it's fine yeah anyone
would have done it it's an old hat
you would have done the same thing
well it is good i mean
i wonder if there is a point in training
that you could get to where you would
feel confident or if that
thing in you would always be like nah
that's not me i don't want to well i
mean i think
homeless people is there there are a lot
of them are on uh narcotics really and
um
yeah so they can be a little
unpredictable yeah it's hard to imagine
feeling good just beating the [ __ ] of a
homeless guy i mean like that was that
went well do you
i totally disagree
you know if a guy's threatening you yeah
i'm gonna say i could but i would feel
good if i could and right it didn't feel
nice you should come in here and be like
the greatest thing yeah yeah yeah the
guy tried to throw me on the train
tracks like karate chopped him
would that be great if you want to do an
mma gym because you want to learn the
most lethal karate chops i need the just
chops i just want to do karate chops
oh well look
joe list you are an absolute pleasure
thank you very much you're well you're
an artist yeah i mean it's it's a
multi-talented one at that yeah comedy
is just one thing right right and that's
i mean if you want to see joe do comedy
that's one of them and you don't
uh february 15th they'll be in houston
the 19th atlantic city later in february
key west then in march tampa then back
to boston in april you can go to
comedian joe list.com i just watched
your uh
first set on letterman oh thanks posted
uh uh reposted on your youtube page
recently so you can look that up uh and
follow him at joe list comedy
of course tuesdays with stories uh
available weekly wherever you get
podcasts
it's always a pleasure oh thanks guys i
appreciate it this is a lot of fun